their God said don't kill shipwreck
survivors and now you're alive so their
God saved your life the concept of God
in and of itself saved your life concept
what is the definition of concept it's
an abstract idea now this idea can be
false or it can be real
so guys if you are somebody who trains
like me when I'm doing boxing when I'm
joking when I'm doing bodybuilding this
can benefit you it's shilajit from
Nature's Blends as you guys know I get
my honey my black seed oil and many
other supplements from them it has 86
plus minerals including zinc magnesium
selenium fulvic acid and 59 fully lab
tested the highest in the market boost
testosterone levels Boost energy levels
and safe for men and women so check out
Nature's Blends in the description box
and enjoy it guys so basically Andrew
take down an interview with validatement
and in the video as you can see there
were some people tweeting some Muslims
were a bit upset they deemed him to say
things that were borderline disbelief
and all this kind of stuff are going on
so I thought as a revert of 10 years let
me show you my experience and also let's
react to these videos one by one and see
why certain people are taking things out
of context and one thing that we need to
understand before the video starts very
clear I've been a Muslim for 10 years
and guys when I first came to Islam Musa
would know Musa my friend who I lived in
this house when got kicked out would
know I used to do stuff like touch wood
yes I would do that in front of people
like bro what are you doing I'm like
what and he's like you can't do that
there'll be stuff like I would have the
Turkish eye in my car these were things
that you gradually let go of so people
need to understand Andrew Tate is new to
Islam he spent more time inside a prison
than outside as a Muslim he is on house
arrest there are many many examples of
excuses we can make even certain
companions who came to Islam when they
were going to war they had these
superstitious beliefs of tying their
swords on a tree for some kind of
blessing and they even went to the
prophet Muhammad asked them the
messenger of God who came with sohee the
Oneness of God and asked him can you
make us such a tree so let's get
straight into the video and understand
what did he mean by that and let's give
some clarifications and give the benefit
of the doubt to our brother who's new to
Islam regardless of whether you're an
atheist or not you're thinking of God as
a man in the sky but you need to think
of God as a concept as a whole and once
you do that it's impossible to accept
that he doesn't exist right you're in
your friendship right on one Island your
friend goes and he crashes and they they
kill him and they eat him and you go to
another Island and they want to kill you
and eat you but they don't because it's
against their religion
did God save your life
who cares who doesn't know the name of
their God but their God said don't kill
Shipwrecked survivors and now you're
alive so their God saved your life the
concept of God in and of itself saved
your life you owe God just for the
concept of it the idea of it okay so
let's just touch up on that which is one
of the biggest contentions a lot of
people had concept what is the
definition of concept it's an abstract
idea now this idea can be false or it
can be real but the example that he's
given and like I said before guys let's
just understand and maybe you should do
a message to our brother Andrew is the
following now there can be false
Concepts that can cause you to think
that you survived for example if I go
out with my family in the forest and I
go stay away from these mushrooms yeah I
don't know nothing about those mushrooms
if you touch that mushroom you'll die or
if you eat it you'll die now the
mushroom itself maybe is not harmful at
all it's just a healthy mushroom but the
concept that I have brought up to my
family
do I then say okay we survived the
forest because we didn't touch that
mushroom or did we didn't eat it not
necessarily it's a false concept
therefore some people are accusing you
and I'm here to defend you in the sense
that if you are seeing like if
somebody's saying that the God is just
the concept then this is problematic why
because we do not believe got to be a
concept like in the Quran Allah says
one he is self-sufficient he does not
beget nor is he begotten and there is
nothing like on him we have clear
descriptions of you goddess so it's not
a concept we believe that he really
exists so like imagine the island
example that you gave if there are a
couple of islands and in those islands
one of them is for example they have
this belief that you should not harm
people or shipwreck [__] Shipwrecked
okay good unless there's another Island
which believes the same thing but they
believe in a different God they have an
idol and let's say there's another
Island where there's Christians and May
believe the same thing now all of them
are applying the same concept of not
Harmony individual now which one have
they've got is the true God because when
we say God save them okay but which one
of them because they all believe in some
kind of a god that is different one
believes in an idol One Believes it's
Jesus One Believes we say no God
ultimately saved you and it is the true
one God which you believe in our brother
Andrew it's Allah so I understand what
he was trying to say and we should give
the benefit of Doubt again in this
specific aspect so we need to understand
that when we say God as a concept we
need to understand that God is a real
it's real he is real it's not just a
concept he is real so we assume the best
so for those Muslims who are getting
upset Brothers understand he's the new
Muslim he's been in prison he's spent
Ramadan in prison so please give the
benefit of the doubt to your brother
it's not damn hard so hope that
clarifies that specific uh area that you
touched upon now let's move on to the
next issue some Muslims had a problem I
would be friends with a gay person yes
I'm a Muslim but I would be friends the
gay person because if a full grown man
decides to make a decision it's his
decision to make but I must protect
innocence as a man so I must protect
children if two men if two full-grown
men decide to have a fight let him fight
if a full-grown man decides to pick on a
kid that's unacceptable so I must
protect innocence so I agree with the
extremism point but I have no problem
with full grown men doing what they want
to do maybe some Islamic school who's
going to watch this and get mad at me I
don't have a problem with gate with gay
people and being friends with the gay
person okay so being friends with a gay
person I mean I'm not Islamic scholar
and I did watch this interview and once
again brothers and sisters we need to
understand what he means I'm very simple
do I would I be friends with a game of
them depends what you mean by friend
look there is some individuals that I
know who I actually did discussion in
the park who who is a brother who had
inclination to homosexuality I speak to
him I've got his what's up number we
speak regularly I have we can even say
in I have a brother in Islam which is
brother Hussein who I spoke to he's my
brother in Islam who's has these
Tendencies you know so I don't think you
can be shunned all the extremist uh you
know
um that you can't be friends so that
notion doesn't exists we hate the sin
but we do not hate The Sinner unless
that sinner is propagating it so yes
just to clarify that as well let's go to
the next clip truly and I want to make
one more point I do believe there is one
God and I believe there's many different
paths to God
okay good so he says that he believes in
one God which again affirms what he said
guys that he believes in the Oneness of
God but there are many paths to God
um we don't know what exactly that means
but we believe that there is only one
path to God Allah says in the Quran that
he's chosen Islam for us and it is only
Islam that he will accept from us
um different people have different
Journeys and we need to understand
something very simple and clear the
burning sisters sometimes certain things
look it might be that Andrew Tate came
to Islam for the wrong reasons but guess
what he may be staying in Islam for the
right reasons how I one of the reasons I
accepted Islam was the scientific
Miracles I'll be honest with you and now
we know that this whole scientific
Miracles was actually nonsense not told
in total but guess what Allah led me to
Islam one of the reasons was because of
the scientific Miracles and guess what
did I leave Islam in this whole
scientific Miracle thing got debunked no
I stayed because I grew in faith and
that's what Allah says in the Quran to
the Bedouins don't say you have believed
but rather says you have submitted they
were better do in Arabs and Allah says
because Iman hasn't entered your heart
what does Allah say in the Quran it says
the Bedouins say we have believed say
you have not yet believed but rather say
we have submitted for for faith has not
entered your hearts if you obey Allah in
his messenger he will not deprive you
from your Deeds or anything so which is
very clear meaning Faith hasn't come
into your heart yet so every Muslim is
every movement is a Muslim but not every
Muslim is a movement A True True
Believer in that sense this comes with
time which is one of the reasons I'm
doing this video because we know very
clearly our brother Andrew Tate is a
Muslim is he a mean yet no not just yet
he'll be working towards that so this
clearly shows us the following but Allah
also mentions
and the verse goes on and that they will
have a great reward so we need to
understand we give him the benefit of
doubt he's you're learning and I highly
highly encourage him and if prophetam
Khan is watching this which I'm sure he
will be I was actually going to do this
video because I heard some things about
himself alhamdulillah clarified Mia
which I was speaking to him today and he
said you're actually a very lovely
person and you are not ascribed to those
individuals which I don't want to get
into who deem everyone to be misguided
and don't listen to Mufti mango unless
that person and I'm gonna see pictures
with you and mostly men it shows that
you are your own man and you're not
falling for these individuals who
backbites and slam the individuals so
I'm very happy I spoke to Apple Tamia he
actually kind of calmed me down a bit
and told me what kind of a person you
are and I'm so happy to hear that so I
would say Tom Khan if you're watching
this please get Andrew Tate connected to
ustad abutemia he is the perfect person
and and and I just say this in a nice
way that Andrew taters knew he's
learning he should have some teachers
and I'm sure he does that can help him
on this path inshallah that will clarify
for him the Deen we all have teachers I
have teachers to this day you know that
till the day I die to learn and uh to
educate himself inshallah slowly slowly
about Islam inshallah so that people
don't pick up on these little
misunderstandings primary function of a
religion I don't believe this the
religion exists so I can forever I mean
that's a that's a nice thought but I
think on a macro level the primary
objective of a religion is to restore
and contain some degree of traditional
value okay that's true of course
religion is there to sustain some
traditional Traditional Values
throughout our life and to live through
the moral compass of Islam however we
cannot say religions there just for that
reason and he said obviously religion is
not there for him to live forever he
might mean maybe living physically
forever but in the sense for example if
we're looking at the Quran Allah says it
is he who created life and death to test
you and so that it can be proven unto
proven who has the best of actions so
very clearly this means that Allah said
that he has created us for the purpose
that he can test us and Allah says in
the Quran that we have not created for
no other reason except to worship him
our whole life everything that we do
should be for the sake of God and in his
worship and his remembrance and Allah
says in the Quran also we did not create
this worldly life for enjoyment and fun
there is a purpose you know that's why
Allah says
and you know race this race that you're
in this rap race you're in until you
visit the graves and then you will
surely know so God Almighty is telling
us this world is temporary the biggest
goal is what the Eternal living which is
what we're going to live forever our
souls are gonna live forever which is
Paradise or hell and for those who are
still saying no you just make can uh you
know just defending no look at this next
video that he said if I could lie right
now for 10 million dollars I and nobody
would find out nobody
still couldn't do it because God would
know and he punched me similarly I
really truly believe that I would pay
the price of that life
I truly believe
now there you go that is
an aspect of tawheed knowing that if
nobody can hear him that he will still
not do it he has belief he has Iman
there saying that he would be
accountable not only that we know the
Hadith of the man who committed so many
sins that he told his sons when I die
that get my body and turn it into ashes
and Scatter it around for I fear that if
Allah got hold of me he will give me a
punishment he would never give now if
you think about it he's actually
negating you know which I would like to
ask her brother to Rago about this if
you think about he's actually negating
action of Allah that Allah cannot bring
him together with some of them did and
Allah brought him brought him back
because Allah has that capability and he
asked him why did you do that why did
you say that why did you ask him to do
this he said because I feared you and
guess what Allah forgave him because he
acknowledged that Allah he was so scared
of Allah that it's as if he went a bit
like he lost the prop by thinking that
God can't put him together the one who
created the heavens and earth so it's
very clear from the statement and he
believes in Allah it's not just the
concept that some Muslims are upset over
give him the benefit of Doubt next clip
and we're going to end inshallah I like
to see myself as a person whose respect
you have to earn I like to see myself as
a person who has strong rigid boundaries
I like to see myself as the person
who'll stand up and say no that's wrong
I like to see myself as a person who's
not afraid of being shamed by whatever
Community for saying I don't agree with
that particular ideal I like seeing
myself that way so if I'm going to see
myself that way then I'm going to
naturally align with a religion that
operates within that form okay Andrew
that's well and good but you need to
understand that that shouldn't just be
the criteria once again Brothers you
need to understand he's just making some
connections where he seems similarities
and one of the reasons I came to Islam
is because I saw the gradual decline of
my family members my culture just
becoming more and more westernized
assimilating literally losing everything
like these days our weddings are full of
like literally it's a nightclub
miniskirts uh alcohol
music it's crazy they were not like that
before this is what happens when you
don't have a religion like Malcolm X
said in if you don't stand for something
you'll fall for anything and I found a
connection with Islam so he's meaning in
that sense where he sees those values
that he already have and he sees in
Islam that's well and good of course but
we should also bear in mind that for
example we should follow Islam not based
on how many people follow it or it has
the Traditional Values Etc but based on
it being the truth from God that's very
important the reason you need to sleep
with not sleep with but date lots of
women when you're younger so you have
choices which Define the two yeah which
is more important date or sleep in your
eyes I feel like you don't really I I
think that sleeping with a woman you
learn more about them is a closer
relationship so I'd say probably sleep
with x amount not crazy amounts but I
would say that okay let me give an
example
if I go to the supermarket and pick up
an apple and it's the only Apple I've
ever eaten
can I really say it's a good apple or a
bad apple
it's the only Apple I've ever tasted it
might be sour it might be terrible I
don't know because if I try 10 apples I
can tell the differences between Apples
I said what's a good apple what's a bad
apple I think you need that degree of
experience because sometimes you'll be
with a woman and go yeah she's great but
if you're not experienced enough you
realize she really isn't all that great
she actually treats you like a [__]
whereas if you've been with enough women
you can always reference back to that
girl who actually was okay here I would
have to give in this guitar brother
Andrew if he's watching this yeah okay
here what you're saying is not correct
why my brother because at the end of the
day it's Haram adultery is enough for a
man or a woman is the same the
punishment's the same if you're not
married it's the same if you're married
it's the same in the Hereafter it's the
same so here I would say
um just be a bit careful and understand
that look like it's not permissible it's
as simple as that categorically it is
Haram now I would just like to maybe see
it from a different perspective like I
believe for example that anybody who has
never tried an apple before a strawberry
for that matter let's let's stick to
Apple here's an example of Apple him
trying the Apple for the first time or
her
she might be thinking this is tasty or
whatever it is yes if they try different
apples it's going to do what cause more
problems like they say like they say
comparison is the biggest destroy of
pleasure you know so the point is what
if that person tries the Apple that's
all he knows that's only tasted that's
all he knows for Apple to be so he's
going to be happy and content with that
thing but if I give another Apple that's
sweeter he's going to say uh that was
not nice so do you see how this can work
for a man or a woman which well does
that mean that now A woman has to go and
have multiple partners and to find out
uh that that first Apple was bad or that
person that they were were not good or
Etc not really that's how we have tawach
and Allah We Trust Allah we don't take
everything into our hands and think let
me go and do ABCD no we say we have
trust in Allah we go about things the
right way and then Halal way and we hope
that Allah will grant us a good woman
it's in the hands of Allah not
necessarily everything is in our control
Islam very categorically says it is
Haram so I would say my brother Andrew
please just be careful with this because
there are a lot of people that follow
you and Islam in Islam it is totally
prohibited to be sleeping around and we
say you put your trust in Allah you stay
away from sex outside of marriage if you
do you if you get indulging it you
repent and that's it so that's the only
thing I wanted to say guys and once
again I reiterated someone might come to
Islam for the wrong reasons and stay in
it for the right reasons so guys please
give be patient and stop nitpicking and
stop trying to attack him he is new be
patient with him inshallah I know how it
is I was a river of myself if people
came and bombarded me at one point they
did it really put me off till next time